Jake: 拍一个跟他们斗舞
Jake: Let's film a dance battle with them.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake: 跟他们斗舞
Jake: Dance battle with them.
Jake: 斗是什么
Jake: What's a dance battle?
Lucia: 好厉害啊
Lucia: So cool.
Tasha: 就是有一个棍子拼控制另一根棍子
Tasha: It's like using one stick to control another stick.
Alice:能玩一下吗
Alice: Can I try it?
Alice:花棍
Alice: Flower stick.
Jake: 花棍
Jake: Flower stick.
其他人：花棍
Others: Flower stick.
Jake: 像是那种打打扫厕所呵
Jake: It's like something you'd use to clean the toilet, huh.
Jake: 呵是
Jake: Huh, right.
Jake: 这练多久啊
Jake: How long have you been practicing this?
Jake: 能能练这样
Jake: To be able to do this?
其他人：您练快
Others: You practice fast.
其他人：您练个十天半个月
Others: You practice for ten days to half a month.
Jake: 半个月半个月就会玩了
Jake: Half a month, and you'll be able to play.
Alice:怎么发力呢
Alice: How do you exert force?
Jake: 要要要不哎
Jake: You, you, you, oh...
Jake: 哎呦我去
Jake: Oh my!
Jake: 哈哈绕了3圈挺厉害
Jake: Haha, spinning 3 circles is pretty impressive.
Jake: 好离谱的数据我靠
Jake: Such ridiculous data, wow.
Alice:哦
Alice: Oh.
其他人：这也是个平衡力
Others: This is also a balance skill.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
其他人：你要掌握它这个
Others: You need to master this.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Tasha: 迫不及待哦
Tasha: Can't wait!
Alice:我能使两个棍弄起来吗
Alice: Can I use two sticks to do it?
其他人：别揪这毛不能揪这个毛
Others: Don't pull this hair, you can't pull this hair.
Lucia: 我
Lucia: I...
Jake: 你厉害
Jake: You're amazing.
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
其他人：哎不要不要卷这个毛
Others: Hey, don't, don't roll this hair.
Shure: 不好意思不好意思
Shure: Sorry, sorry.
其他人：这毛跟头发一样给头发弄掉
Others: This hair is like hair, it will come off like hair.
Jake: 这自怎么自己做的
Jake: How did you make this yourself?
Jake: 外边买
Jake: Bought it outside?
其他人：这开始是买的现在我自己做我也卖
Others: Initially, I bought it, now I make it myself and also sell it.
Jake: 哦哦哦也卖哦
Jake: Oh, oh, you also sell it.
Alice:谢谢
Alice: Thanks.
Jake: 要不咱两个扔试试
Jake: How about we try throwing it together?
Jake: 哎呦厉害
Jake: Oh wow, impressive.
其他人：两个的比一个的难度大多了
Others: Using two is much harder than one.
Jake: 这两个棍
Jake: These two sticks.
其他人：因为是一个左手一个右手
Others: Because one is for the left hand, and one is for the right hand.
Jake: 两两两个棍两个棍
Jake: Two, two, two sticks, two sticks.
其他人：两个棍两个棍行
Others: Two sticks, two sticks, okay.
Jake: 两个棍容易一点
Jake: Two sticks are a bit easier.
其他人：这个你看看热闹行玩玩行
Others: You can watch for fun, it's okay to play.
其他人：你要打算学这个你要从基础学起
Others: If you want to learn this, you need to start from the basics.
Jake: 耶
Jake: Yay.
Jake: 转起来了
Jake: It's spinning.
Jake: 就刚刚刚刚那一段
Jake: Just that part from earlier.
Jake: 然后就重复剪出来
Jake: Then just repeat and cut it out.
Jake: 重复你就一直转
Jake: Keep spinning and repeating.
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Jake: 哈哈哈GIF出来了
Jake: Haha, the GIF is ready.
Jake: 哦可以
Jake: Oh, that's good.
Jake: 够剪了够剪了够剪了
Jake: Enough to cut, enough to cut.
Shure: 谢谢您
Shure: Thank you.
其他人：没事
Others: No problem.
Jake: 谢谢您
Jake: Thank you.
Jake: 我们最后转到原来的位置
Jake: Let's turn back to the original spot.
Jake: 这样整个公园就重建出来了
Jake: That way, the whole park will be rebuilt.
Alice:啊差不多就围湖一圈
Alice: Yeah, pretty much around the lake.
Jake: 好
Jake: Alright.
Alice:这个小亭子还挺凉快的通风
Alice: This little pavilion is pretty cool and breezy.
Jake: 对这亭子挺好
Jake: Yeah, this pavilion is nice.
Alice:噢那个那个上面黏黏的
Alice: Oh, that part is sticky.
Alice:他就增加那个粘性
Alice: It just adds that stickiness.
Lucia: 啊摩擦摩擦力吗
Lucia: Oh, the friction?
Alice:嗯就那个皮上面有那个黏黏的油
Alice: Yeah, the leather has that sticky oil on it.
Jake: 妙啊
Jake: Brilliant.
Alice:搓一下吧
Alice: Give it a rub.
Jake: 湖水洗一洗
Jake: Wash it in the lake.
Alice:太太臭了哈哈
Alice: It's too smelly, haha.
Katrina:  还好有这个事顶一下不然话就会被骂
Katrina: Good thing we have this to distract us; otherwise, we'd get scolded.
Katrina:  也可以往里走哎
Katrina: We can also go inside.
Alice:禁止钓鱼
Alice: No fishing allowed.
Tasha: 这是冰的吗
Tasha: Is this ice?
Tasha: 我想喝矿泉水
Tasha: I want to drink some mineral water.
Tasha: 好像他们还
Tasha: Seems like they still...
Tasha: 这怎么这么贵
Tasha: Why is this so expensive?
Jake: 是的专业
Jake: Yeah, professional.
Tasha: 看看多少钱
Tasha: Let's see how much it is.
Tasha: 是3块钱
Tasha: It's 3 yuan.
Tasha: 怎么办识别不出来
Tasha: What to do, it can't be recognized.
Jake: 刚刚那段其实挺好的忘了
Jake: That part just now was actually pretty good, forgot it.
Jake: 看下一段
Jake: Let's watch the next part.
Alice:这颜色好漂亮
Alice: The color is so pretty.
Tasha: 这个树吗
Tasha: This tree?
Alice:对呀
Alice: Yeah
Tasha: 鸡爪7哦
Tasha: Chicken Claw 7
Alice:好漂亮好漂亮
Alice: So pretty, so pretty
Jake: 叫啥呀
Jake: What's it called?
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Huh?
Jake: 叫什么呀
Jake: What's it called?
Tasha: 爪7
Tasha: Claw 7
Jake: 鸡爪7
Jake: Chicken Claw 7
Tasha: 是的他长得像鸡爪子一样
Tasha: Yeah, it looks like a chicken claw
Jake: 好想吃啊
Jake: I really want to eat it
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Huh?
Jake: 也想吃
Jake: I want to eat it too
Tasha: 那我给你摘一片你吃吧
Tasha: Then I'll pick a piece for you to eat
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 我还以为打开方式是
Lucia: I thought the way to open it was
Lucia: 我们晚上吃鸡爪呢
Lucia: We were going to eat chicken feet tonight
Jake: 呵呵是这个意思
Jake: Haha, that's what it means
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Jake: 呵呵来给我试叶子可能是
Jake: Haha, come let me try the leaf maybe
Tasha: 是吗
Tasha: Really?
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha
Tasha: 这个
Tasha: This one
Shure:  我说我说这里面有蛤蟆啊叫了
Shure: I said, I said there's a frog in here calling
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Huh?
Shure:  听到了蟾蜍的叫声
Shure: I heard the toad croaking
Shure:  稍微践踏一下
Shure: Step on it a bit
Jake: 找手串呢
Jake: Looking for a bracelet
Shure:  我听到了
Shure: I heard it
Jake: 找蛤蟆了
Jake: Looking for the toad
Shure:  哈哈蛤蟆听取蛙声一片
Shure: Haha, the toad listens to the sound of frogs
Shure:  哇哇
Shure: Wow wow
Alice:想从这走过去
Alice: Want to walk over from here
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Jake: 比谁走得快
Jake: Race to see who walks faster
Jake: 到那个呃真的走
Jake: To that, uh, really walk
Lucia: 不行底下都有水
Lucia: No way, there's water everywhere below
Lucia: 没有落脚点
Lucia: No place to step
Tasha: 很滑的
Tasha: It's very slippery
Jake: 对
Jake: Right
Lucia: 掉进去了的话
Lucia: If it falls in
Jake: 这个
Jake: This
Lucia: AI就会捕获人类早期落水宝贵纪录
Lucia: The AI will capture valuable early records of humans falling into the water
Jake: 是这是他捕捉的最后一个信号
Jake: Yes, this is the last signal it captured
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahaha
Lucia: 哦然后进水就坏了是吗
Lucia: Oh, and then it breaks when it gets wet, right?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes
Alice:AI能不能理解我们为什么非要从这走
Alice: Can the AI understand why we insist on going this way?
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yes
Lucia: 他就最后总结出人类都太不理性了
Lucia: It would conclude that humans are just too irrational
Lucia: 然后决定消灭人类吗
Lucia: And then decide to eliminate humans?
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Lucia: 我看了好多类似的科幻片哈哈
Lucia: I've seen many sci-fi movies like that, haha
Jake: 哦是吧
Jake: Oh, really?
Tasha: 桃花潭水
Tasha: Taohua Tan water
其他人：深千尺
Others: A thousand feet deep
Shure:  前面这条是京杭大运河
Shure: This is the Beijing-Hangzhou Grand Canal
Jake: 哪一条啊
Jake: Which one?
Tasha: 真的吗潜在的这条河
Tasha: Really, this potential river?
Tasha: 我们就可以回家了阿sir
Tasha: We can go home, officer
Jake: 确实
Jake: Indeed
Jake: 那你的那个手链在杭州可以能找到
Jake: Then your bracelet might be found in Hangzhou
Shure:  你怎么知道我过一段要去杭州
Shure: How did you know I would go to Hangzhou later?
Jake: 那你去找找
Jake: Then you should look for it
Tasha: 噔噔噔噔
Tasha: Dun dun dun dun
Jake: 先录一段
Jake: Let's record a bit first
Alice:晚上在这应该挺舒服
Alice: It should be quite comfortable here at night
Tasha: 哔哔哔哔哔
Tasha: Beep beep beep beep beep
Alice:晚上逛公园很舒服
Alice: Walking in the park at night is very pleasant
Tasha: 哔哔
Tasha: Beep beep
Tasha: baby
Tasha: Baby
Jake: 贴了一个符就防虫了上面
Jake: Putting a talisman on it will keep the bugs away
Tasha: 无法从胶带上下来
Tasha: Can't get off the tape
Jake: 哦这么好这
Jake: Oh, is it that good?
Tasha: 然后就死在树上
Tasha: And then it dies on the tree
Tasha: 当然你相信了吗
Tasha: Of course, do you believe it?
Jake: 我信
Jake: I do
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay
Tasha: 这棵树好恶心呀
Tasha: This tree is so gross
Alice:啥呀
Alice: What?
Tasha: 我说这个树好恶心啊
Tasha: I said this tree is so gross
Alice:麻麻赖赖的
Alice: It's so slimy
Jake: 这是什么呀
Jake: What is this?
Tasha: 这棵树好好
Tasha: This tree is nice
Tasha: 墓地
Tasha: Cemetery
Jake: 对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah
Alice:这有个坟包
Alice: There's a grave here
Tasha: 哦天呐
Tasha: Oh my god
Alice:这公园是不是就是为他建的
Alice: Is this park built for him?
Tasha: 李治好像
Tasha: Li Zhi, I think
Jake: 不止吧刚刚好像看到别
Jake: Not just him, I think I saw others
Jake: 的墓地好像是
Jake: Other graves, I think
Alice:原来是个大墓园啊
Alice: So it's a big cemetery
Jake: 嗯哼可以是或者是原来有一个公园
Jake: Yeah, could be, or maybe there used to be a park
Jake: 然后谁想埋着埋一下
Jake: And people just buried here
Jake: 住附近的埋一下
Jake: People living nearby buried here
Alice:这是海棠吧
Alice: Is this a crabapple tree?
Tasha: 嗯是的吧
Tasha: Yeah, I think so
Alice:像海棠海棠啊
Alice: Looks like a crabapple tree
Alice:已经过了观赏季了
Alice: It's past the blooming season
Alice:最多看看郁金香估计就
Alice: At most, you can see some tulips, maybe
Tasha: 哪有郁金香
Tasha: Where are the tulips?
Alice:我说这个季节
Alice: I mean this season
Alice:芍药牡丹之类的
Alice: Peonies and stuff
Shure:  你好害怕
Shure: You're so scared
Shure:  你好可怕呀
Shure: You're so scary
Shure:  你这个就是就是就是
Shure: You're just just just
Jake: 为啥呀我这一棒槌下去是吧
Jake: Why? If I hit you with this stick, right?
Shure:  一脸严肃
Shure: So serious
Shure:  然后架着肩膀就这样走
Shure: Then you raise your shoulders and walk like this
Shure:  我爬山
Shure: I'm climbing
Jake: 来爬山这是什么山
Jake: Climbing? What mountain is this?
Alice:未名山
Alice: Unnamed Mountain
Lucia: 陡坡路华山
Lucia: Steep Road Mountain
Katrina:  情人坡
Katrina: Lover's Slope
Jake: 陡坡路华山好嘞
Jake: Steep Road Mountain, got it
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Lucia: 不知道是哪几个字有诗意的呢哈哈
Lucia: I wonder which words are poetic, haha.
Jake: 是是是一个华山
Jake: Yes, yes, it's a Huashan Mountain.
Jake: 简称华山
Jake: It's called Huashan Mountain.
Jake: 我们在爬华山
Jake: We're climbing Huashan Mountain.
Jake: 香山哈哈哈哈嘿
Jake: Xiangshan, hahaha, hey.
Katrina:  没见过紫丁香
Katrina: Never seen lilacs.
Alice:白丁香
Alice: White lilacs.
Tasha: 哇好清澈呀
Tasha: Wow, so clear.
Jake: 这到公路了
Jake: We've reached the road.
Jake: 能开车了
Jake: We can drive now.
Jake: 这是出园了吗
Jake: Are we out of the park?
Jake: 还是啥意思
Jake: Or what does this mean?
Jake: 这小台阶挺好
Jake: These small steps are nice.
Alice:梯田
Alice: Terraces.
Alice:雷峰塔
Alice: Leifeng Pagoda.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哦原来这塔不在这里边
Lucia: Oh, so the pagoda isn't here.
Jake: 可以过去吧
Jake: Can we go over there?
Jake: 问问问
Jake: Let's ask.
Jake: 问看看
Jake: Let's ask and see.
Jake: 这有个地图倒是可以看看
Jake: There's a map here, we can take a look.
Jake: 哎咱在哪啊
Jake: Hey, where are we?
Alice:您的位置
Alice: Your location.
Jake: 在哪啊
Jake: Where?
Lucia: 这个有一个小星号的地方
Lucia: There's a little asterisk here.
Jake: 这个
Jake: Here?
Lucia: 您在这里
Lucia: You're here.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
其他人：好热啊
Others: It's so hot.
其他人：我下次再遇到那个售货机我一定要喝那个桃子饮料
Others: Next time I see that vending machine, I'm definitely getting that peach drink.
其他人：刚刚路过一个我就看到好想买
Others: We just passed one and I really wanted to buy it.
Tasha: 我刚刚想买但你们都走远了
Tasha: I wanted to buy it earlier, but you all walked away.
其他人： 就是售货机里有一个饮料
Others: There's a drink in the vending machine.
其他人：我还挺想买的
Others: I really wanted to buy it.
Tasha: 我刚刚看你想买你们都走了
Tasha: I saw you wanted to buy it, but you all walked away.
Tasha: 然后我在那
Tasha: And then I was there.
Jake: 哦售货机
Jake: Oh, the vending machine.
其他人：下次再遇到我们就买
Others: Next time we see it, we should buy it.
Jake: 好一会转
Jake: Okay, let's circle back.
Jake: 转到最后的这个地方
Jake: Circle back to the last place.
Jake: 然后再多走一段
Jake: Then let's walk a bit more.
Shure:  我只想要瓶水
Shure: I just want a bottle of water.
Tasha: 那个桃子饮料汁
Tasha: That peach drink.
其他人：对对对
Others: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Tasha: 我当时在想他是冰的还是常温的
Tasha: I was wondering if it's cold or at room temperature.
Tasha: 冰的还是常温的
Tasha: Cold or room temperature.
其他人：应该是冰的
Others: It should be cold.
Tasha: 然后我就在那等了半天
Tasha: Then I waited there for a long time.
Tasha: 然后我开始人脸识别发现识别不上
Tasha: Then I tried facial recognition and it didn't work.
其他人：啊
Others: Ah.
Tasha: 然后开始拿支付宝
Tasha: Then I started using Alipay.
Tasha: 我发现你们已经走了
Tasha: I realized you guys had already left.
其他人：下次再遇到一定买一瓶
Others: Next time we meet, definitely buy a bottle.
其他人：我们在哪呢
Others: Where are we?
Katrina:  刚刚进来的地方
Katrina: The place we just came in.
Tasha:  （歌词）你的笑容已泛黄
Tasha: (lyrics) Your smile has turned yellow.
Tasha: 听说你也是LFP
Tasha: I heard you're also LFP.
其他人：对啊我也是
Others: Yeah, I am too.
Tasha: 从来不参与这些讨论
Tasha: Never participate in these discussions.
Tasha: 服从
Tasha: Obey.
其他人：是的
Others: Yes.
Lucia: 好热呀
Lucia: So hot.
其他人：我们三个NFP聚在一起
Others: The three of us NFPs together.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Lucia: 啊对
Lucia: Ah, right.
Tasha: 不错蝴蝶开会
Tasha: Not bad, butterfly meeting.
Lucia: 蝴蝶开会哈哈
Lucia: Butterfly meeting, haha.
其他人：对
Others: Yeah.
Tasha: 走开这里是蝴蝶的盛宴哈哈哈
Tasha: Go away, this is a butterfly feast, haha.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake: 我们去买水吧
Jake: Let's go buy water.
Tasha: 好呀
Tasha: Sure.
Jake: 买到就是绕到入口的地方
Jake: If we get it, we'll loop back to the entrance.
Tasha: 刚刚你们没看到我的那个地方
Tasha: You guys didn't see my spot earlier.
Lucia: 蝴蝶诱捕器哈哈哈
Jake: 哈哈哈蝴蝶应该怎么抓呀
Jake: Haha, how should we catch butterflies?
Jake: 拿网抓是吧
Jake: With a net, right?
Lucia: 啊没有
Lucia: Ah, no.
Jake: 没有我现在
Jake: No, I now...
Lucia: 我们是在说怎么形容
Lucia: We were talking about how to describe it.
Jake: 哈哈这个是蝴蝶诱捕器
Jake: Haha, this is a butterfly trap.
Lucia: 对对对对对
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, yeah, right.
Jake: 你们就过来了是吧
Jake: So you guys just came over, right?
Tasha: 哈哈好
Tasha: Haha, okay.
Lucia: 我们三个是蝴蝶
Lucia: The three of us are butterflies.
Lucia: 这是诱捕器
Lucia: This is the trap.
Jake: oh OK
Jake: Oh, OK.
Jake: 走吧我们绕回去
Jake: Let's go, we'll circle back.
Tasha: 今天怎么不穿绿色
Tasha: Why aren't you wearing green today?
Tasha: 你已经被踢出我们蝴蝶工会了
Tasha: You've been kicked out of our butterfly guild.
Lucia: 哦这样啊
Lucia: Oh, really?
Tasha: 哈哈哈我还有
Tasha: Haha, I still have...
Jake: 我还有我还有一个裤子是绿色
Jake: I still have a pair of green pants.
Lucia: 今天好像没
Lucia: Seems like not today.
Lucia: 这次出来好像没带绿衣服
Lucia: I didn't bring any green clothes this time.
Lucia: 早知道应该带一条绿裙子
Lucia: I should have brought a green dress.
Jake: 蝴蝶有绿色的吗
Jake: Do butterflies even come in green?
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Jake: 嗯好像不太有
Jake: Hmm, doesn't seem like it.
Lucia: 好像不太有
Lucia: Doesn't seem like it.
Tasha: 是那个穿着一身绿裙子啊
Tasha: There's one wearing a green dress.
Jake: 精品蝴蝶
Jake: Premium butterfly.
Lucia: 对对那个小人是绿色的
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, that little figure is green.
Tasha:嗯
Tasha: Mm.
Lucia: 小人身边那蝴蝶好像也还真是绿色的
Lucia: The butterfly next to that little figure is actually green too.
Lucia: 哎
Lucia: Hey.
Alice:官方好像每个人格都给出来三个形象
Alice: The official seems to have given each character three images.
Tasha: 还有个什么
Tasha: What else?
Lucia: 还有一个中性形象就是
Lucia: There's also a neutral image, which means...
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Tasha: 还有男蝴蝶
Tasha: There's also a male butterfly.
Tasha: 就是跟我们穿的是不一样的是吧
Tasha: It's different from what we're wearing, right?
Alice:啊是的
Alice: Yes, that's right.
Lucia: 对就是他的形象会有变化
Lucia: Yes, his image changes.
Lucia: 但是代表的都是这个人格
Lucia: But they all represent the same character.
Alice:就平时看见EFP竟然是个女的形象
Alice: Normally, you'd see EFP with a female image.
Lucia: 我一直以为是个
Lucia: I always thought it was a...
Alice:像不像男孩
Alice: Looks like a boy, right?
Lucia: 哦这样啊
Lucia: Oh, really?
Alice:就快乐小狗好像是女的
Alice: It seems like the Happy Puppy is female.
Alice:就给出来的
Alice: They just gave it.
Alice:比较通用的
Alice: It's more general.
Tasha: 那那你的快乐小狗是男的吗
Tasha: So is your Happy Puppy male?
Jake: 啊这个也分吗
Jake: Oh, is there a distinction?
Alice:就是官方是给出来三个形象的
Alice: Yes, they officially gave three images.
Alice:一般只就是我们平时用的只
Alice: Usually, we use just one.
Jake: 哦还有
Jake: Oh, there's more?
Alice:一个是典型的形象
Alice: One is the typical image.
Jake: 型的形象
Jake: The typical image.
Jake: OK OK
Jake: OK, OK.
Tasha: water water water water water water
Lucia: 啊对对
Lucia: Oh, yeah, yeah.
Alice:ESTJ是尺节尺子
Alice: ESTJ is like a ruler.
Lucia: ESTJ我朋友里好像都没有ESTJ
Lucia: I don't think any of my friends are ESTJ.
Katrina:  他上次不是说没有s吗
Katrina: Didn't he say he didn't have an S last time?
Katrina:  因为因为我是这两天才变成了s
Katrina: Because, because I just became an S in the past two days.
Katrina:  那就是唯一一个s人了是不是
Katrina: So, am I the only S person now?
Jake: 啊你怎么突然变成了s
Jake: How did you suddenly become an S?
Katrina:  没有
Katrina: No.
Katrina:  就是好像在就是来北京前一天测的
Katrina: I took the test the day before I came to Beijing.
Jake: 来北京突然变异了
Jake: You mutated suddenly in Beijing.
Katrina:  哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Jake: 果然是变异
Jake: Indeed, you mutated.
Lucia: 你看为什么大家加入你的team都会变
Lucia: See, why does everyone who joins your team change?
Jake: 一直在变异
Jake: Always mutating.
Jake: 好吃的吗
Jake: Is it delicious?
Lucia: 就是本来你说紫藤和那个谢斌竹
Lucia: Originally, you said Violet and Xie Binzhu.
Lucia: 都是换了
Lucia: They both changed.
Lucia: 换了发型
Lucia: Changed their hairstyles.
Jake: 噢真的吗
Jake: Oh, really?
Lucia: 然后然后现在那个
Lucia: Then, then now that.
Jake: 噢OK OK OK
Jake: Oh, OK, OK, OK.
Lucia: 哈哈又有人从n变成了s
Lucia: Haha, someone else turned from an N to an S.
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
Katrina:  对我刚开始
Katrina: Yeah, I just started.
Lucia: 雨轩真的从n变成了s吗
Lucia: Did Yuxuan really change from N to S?
Jake: 你们有一个人从屁变成借我导致
Jake: Someone changed from P to J because of me.
Jake: 能理解哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: I can understand, hahaha.
Lucia: 实话说我这两天已经有点想要变成g
Lucia: Honestly, these past two days, I've been thinking about turning into a G.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Tasha: 因为整个组织的无纪律性
Tasha: Because of the lack of discipline in the whole organization
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Lucia: 不过也挺好的
Lucia: But it's quite nice though
Jake: 哈哈
Jake: Haha
Lucia: 我喜欢一些随机事件发生
Lucia: I like when random things happen
Lucia: 就本质上还是很p
Lucia: It still feels pretty p
Jake: 这个太这个太P了
Jake: This is so p
Jake: 这个太p了
Lucia: 我觉得我大部分的朋友都是NP
Lucia: I think most of my friends are NP
Tasha: what is this
Tasha: What is this
Lucia: 也有这一人
Lucia: There is this one person
Lucia: 但是少一些
Lucia: But fewer of them
Lucia: 但是ESTJ这个组合好像
Lucia: But this ESTJ combination seems to
Alice:看到就想逃
Alice: Makes me want to run away
Lucia: 好像在我的小伙伴里就关系很好
Lucia: It seems like within my friends, the relationship is very good
Lucia: 就是好到大家互相
Lucia: So good that everyone
Lucia: 这种MBTA类型的里面好像没有
Lucia: Within this MBTA type, there doesn't seem to be
Katrina:  但是我闺蜜全是哀人
Katrina: But all my best friends are I types
Tasha: 这棵树上点了好多蜡烛
Tasha: There are so many candles on this tree
Jake: 好多
Jake: So many
Lucia: 哇好热
Lucia: Wow, it's so hot
Lucia: 我随机选一条路吧哈哈
Lucia: I'll randomly choose a path, haha
Jake: 好好我们听j的
Jake: Alright, we'll follow J's lead
Shure: 来来来石头剪刀布
Shure: Let's play rock-paper-scissors
Shure: 赢了就往那边走
Shure: The winner decides which way to go
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah
Lucia: 啊我们要分分组走了吗哦OK OK
Lucia: Are we splitting up? Oh, OK OK
Jake: 没有他们在玄悟
Jake: No, they're just pondering
Jake: 他们做历史的抉择
Jake: They're making historical choices
Lucia: 历史的抉择
Lucia: Historical choices
Alice:历史的分岔路口
Alice: At the crossroads of history
Jake: 走左还是走右啊
Jake: Should we go left or right
Lucia: 啊哈你这有别的意思吗
Lucia: Haha, do you mean something else by that
Jake: 没有别的意思哈哈哈
Jake: No, nothing else, haha
Lucia: 哈哈这段是不是要剪掉啊
Lucia: Haha, should we cut this part out
Shure:  你不要瞎问文本里面没有问题的
Shure: Don't worry, there's nothing wrong with the script
Tasha: 什么叫左左还是左右
Tasha: What do you mean by left-left or left-right
Lucia: 哈哈哈这些放到文本里没有问题
Lucia: Haha, there's no problem including this in the script
Jake: 哈哈什么
Jake: Haha, what
Lucia: 对对确实确实
Lucia: Yes, yes, exactly.
Tasha: 什么叫左左还是左右
Tasha: What do you mean by left or right?
Jake: 没有什么意思就是左
Jake: It doesn't mean anything, just left.
Jake: 向左转还是向右转
Jake: Turn left or turn right.
Shure: 你这是你是在认真的发问是吗
Shure: Are you seriously asking?
Tasha: 对我我没有听懂这个梗
Tasha: Yeah, I didn't get the joke.
Lucia: 其实也没事
Lucia: Actually, it's fine.
Lucia: 这是现在的那个啥也很常见的
Lucia: This kind of thing is quite common now.
Jake: 对对是的是的
Jake: Yes, yes, it is.
Shure:  是
Shure: Yes.
Lucia: 也不一定非得有什么
Lucia: It doesn't necessarily mean anything.
Shure:  在那个时期
Shure: At that time.
Jake: 在那个时期可能就剪刀石头布
Jake: At that time, maybe it was rock-paper-scissors.
Tasha: 还有别的隐喻吗
Tasha: Are there other metaphors?
Lucia: 一定要再多加两两多补两刀吗
Lucia: Do we really need to add two more cuts?
Shure:  左右吗
Shure: Left or right?
Jake: 对对
Jake: Yes, yes.
Tasha: 左右
Tasha: Left or right.
Shure:  那个时期
Shure: At that time.
Jake: 就是就是一分钟之前
Jake: Just like a minute ago.
Lucia: 对对对对是这样的
Lucia: Yes, yes, exactly.
Jake: 没有别的意思
Jake: It doesn't mean anything else.
Jake: 对对因为很难选嘛
Jake: Yes, yes, because it's hard to choose.
Shure: 这个等停止录了再给你科普一下
Shure: I'll explain it to you after we stop recording.
Lucia: 因为现在没岔路了
Lucia: Because now there are no forks in the road.
Tasha: 好科普一下
Tasha: Okay, explain it to me.
Jake: 你在录吧
Jake: Are you recording?
Jake: 我看看你的灯
Jake: Let me check your light.
Shure: 我在录
Shure: I'm recording.
Jake: 哦确实外面看不太清
Jake: Oh, it's hard to see from outside.
Jake: 但是得看一看好的
Jake: But you need to check it.
Tasha: 都在录
Tasha: We're all recording.
Shure:  我斜斜的往上看一眼能看到
Shure: I can see it if I look up slightly.
Jake: 好的
Jake: Okay.
Alice:我这个好像红色的灯
Alice: Mine seems to have a red light.
Jake: 哦那你你看一下
Jake: Oh, check it out then.
Jake: 是不是快没电了还是怎么的
Jake: Maybe it's low on battery or something.
Lucia: 亮好像是还亮着的
Lucia: It seems like it's still on.
Jake: 对红的
Jake: Yes, red.
Jake: 要不就是过热要不就是它过热
Jake: Either it's overheating or it's just overheating.
Jake: 它会报警
Jake: It'll alert you.
Alice:这是有点热了 100%的电
Alice: It's getting a bit hot, 100% charged.
Jake: 100%的电你插电呢是吧
Jake: 100% charged, you're plugging it in, right?
Alice:yes我一直在充
Alice: Yes, I'm constantly charging it.
Tasha: 我们用了这么久还这么多电
Tasha: We've used it for so long and it's still so charged.
Jake: 他插电了
Jake: He's plugging it in.
Alice:因为我在一直充电
Alice: Because I'm constantly charging it.
Jake: 那就合理
Jake: That makes sense.
Jake: 那就是过热
Jake: So it's overheating.
Jake: 应该在阴凉地多走一走
Jake: You should walk around in the shade more.
Jake: 降降温
Jake: Cool it down.
Alice:有点烫烫的嘞
Alice: It's a bit hot.
Jake: 降降温
Jake: Cool it down.
Alice:小蝴蝶
Alice: Little butterfly.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Alice:飞了
Alice: It flew away.
Shure:  有人要滚一圈吗
Shure: Anyone want to roll around?
其他人：他要滚下去
Others: He wants to roll down.
其他人：还是算了吧
Others: Let's not do it.
Shure: 算了吧
Shure: Forget it.
Lucia: 为什么要从这诡异起来
Lucia: Why does it have to be so weird?
Jake: 等不录的话你可以滚下去
Jake: If we're not recording, you can roll down.
Shure:  我说眼镜看好我我给你
Shure: I mean, keep an eye on me, I'll give you...
Lucia: 你把眼镜放到这录着你自己滚下去
Lucia: You put the glasses here and record yourself rolling down.
Shure:  算了别污染数据集了
Shure: Forget it, don't contaminate the dataset.
Shure:  然后它以为人类的行动方式有一个是滚
Shure: Then it'll think one of the human actions is rolling.
Alice:请你圆润的滚开
Alice: Please roll away smoothly.
Lucia: 不是
Lucia: No.
Jake: 就是他
Jake: That's him.
Lucia: 这是早早期人类撒欢的珍贵记录
Lucia: This is a precious record of early humans playing.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake: 就是从此以后就是
Jake: So from now on...
Jake: 呃如果一个人想到那边
Jake: If someone thinks of that place...
Jake: 然后就会Rick man的一个滚下去的做法
Jake: Then they'll have Rick man's way of rolling down.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈真的
Lucia: Hahaha, really.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Jake: 这样效率更高哈哈哈
Jake: This way is more efficient, hahaha.
Lucia: 这是人工智障吧这是
Lucia: Is this artificial stupidity?
Jake: 人工智障那就是
Jake: Artificial stupidity, that's it.
Shure:  因为你看咱们刚才走了一个陡坡
Shure: You know, we just walked up a steep slope.
Shure:  然后咱们走的时间可能就是很慢
Shure: And we were probably walking pretty slowly.
Jake: 哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Shure:  这条路呢
Shure: This path...
Shure:  我从这到那个下坡滚这时间更快了
Shure: If I roll down the slope, it'd be faster.
Lucia: 啊所以
Lucia: Ah, so...
Lucia: 当给出的指令是计算最快路线的时候
Lucia: When the instruction is to find the fastest route...
Lucia: 就会滚
Lucia: It means rolling.
Tasha: 啊就会走这里
Tasha: Ah, then we'd take this path.
Tasha: 走超进道了
Tasha: Taking a shortcut.
Jake: 哎抄近道然后走的话
Jake: Yeah, taking a shortcut and walking...
Alice:高德地图不管我能不能过去
Alice: The map doesn't care if I can actually get through.
Alice:反正他就给我一个穿墙的选项
Alice: It just gives me an option to go through walls.
Alice:是不是也是这样的
Alice: Is it the same for you?
Shure: 有可能
Shure: Possibly.
Jake: 穿墙 这不行
Jake: Going through walls, that's not okay.
Lucia: 那个应该是他数据没及时更新
Lucia: That probably means the data wasn't updated in time.
Lucia: 就是他不知道那分上
Lucia: It doesn't know that part.
Jake: 对这是不够智能
Jake: Yeah, it's not smart enough.
Jake: 就是滚下去是可以实现的
Jake: Rolling down is doable.
Jake: 穿墙是不可实现的
Jake: Going through walls is not.
Lucia: 你怎么知道
Lucia: How do you know?
Lucia: 他不是想让你把墙砸掉啊
Lucia: Maybe it wants you to break the wall down.
Jake: 哈哈哦哈哈哈
Jake: Haha, oh haha.
Alice:管我的死活是吧哈哈哈
Alice: It doesn't care if I live or die, right? Haha.
Alice:哎在这浇花很方便
Alice: It's convenient to water the plants here.
Alice:直接往这一冲
Alice: Just pour the water here.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Alice:水顺着就流下去了
Alice: The water will just flow down.
Jake: 是的
Jake: Exactly.
Shure:  这就是梯田是吗
Shure: So, is this a terrace?
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Shure:  but畸形的钱吗
Shure: But, is it weird money?
Alice:水好亮
Alice: The water is so shiny.
Tasha: 波光粼粼
Tasha: Sparkling.
Alice:粼粼
Alice: Sparkling.
Lucia: 我们现在是要玩飞花令了吗哈哈
Lucia: Are we going to play a poetry game now? Haha.
Jake: 来看你们表演
Jake: Let's see your performance.
Lucia: 没有没有
Lucia: No, no.
Lucia: 就是你们刚才那个波光粼粼
Lucia: It's just that sparkling thing you mentioned.
Lucia: 我突然想起来昨
Lucia: I suddenly remembered yester-
Lucia: 天的成语接龙
Lucia: day’s idiom chain game
Lucia: 然后就想起来废话令那个提案
Lucia: and then I thought of the nonsense proposal
Alice:我先来
Alice: I’ll go first
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
Lucia: 对对巴萨了
Lucia: Yes, yes, Barça
Jake: 这什么球队
Jake: Which team is this?
Jake: 看一下哦
Jake: Let me check
Jake: 阿塞尔的
Jake: Arsenal's
Lucia: 真的在真的在
Lucia: It’s real, it’s real
Lucia: 那个诺坎普买的哈哈
Lucia: Bought at Camp Nou, haha
Jake: OK
Alice:成语接龙
Alice: Idiom chain game
Lucia: 不过不过
Lucia: But, but
Lucia: 我现在不是不是巴萨的球迷了
Lucia: I’m not a Barça fan anymore
Lucia: 也不是不是
Lucia: Not anymore
Lucia: 就是还没有到路转不是
Lucia: Not to the point of turning against them
Lucia: 也没有到粉转黑的程度
Lucia: Not to the point of turning into a hater
Alice:第一个为所欲为
Alice: First one, "Do as one pleases"
Lucia: 就粉转路吧
Lucia: Just turned into a neutral fan
Alice:下一个哈哈哈哈
Alice: Next one, hahaha
Lucia: 因为这两年管理太混乱了
Lucia: Because the management has been too chaotic these past two years
Alice:成语接龙
Alice: Idiom chain game
Jake: OK
Alice:为所欲为
Alice: "Do as one pleases"
Lucia: 我正在试图找一个新球队
Lucia: I’m trying to find a new team
Shure:  维他命 c
Shure: Vitamin C
Lucia: 现在目前的备选是阿森纳
Lucia: Currently, Arsenal is my backup choice
Jake: 阿森纳大炮
Jake: Arsenal cannon
Alice:维他命c也能是成语吗
Alice: Can "Vitamin C" be an idiom?
Jake: 他们在射箭嘛
Jake: They’re shooting arrows
Jake: 有点厉害
Jake: Quite impressive
Jake: 前面那两位
Jake: The two in front
Lucia: 这个车衣看起来好舒服呀
Lucia: This bike jersey looks so comfortable
Tasha: 随便买的
Tasha: Just bought it casually
Jake: 但前面是有卖东西的地方吗
Jake: But is there a place selling things in front?
Katrina:  知道啊
Katrina: I know
Tasha: 社区便利店
Tasha: Community convenience store
Jake: 像吗这个像吗
Jake: Does it look like it?
Jake: 社区便利店确实是
Jake: Community convenience store, indeed
Tasha: 便民
Tasha: Convenient
Shure:  但是他有没有可能在墙那里面呢
Shure: But is it possible he's inside the wall?
Tasha: 让他伸出来
Tasha: Let him reach out
Tasha: 爷爷给我一瓶水
Tasha: Grandpa, give me a bottle of water
Jake: OK
Jake: 手机连成一串
Jake: String the phones together
Jake: 谢谢您哎呀
Jake: Thank you, oh man
Jake: 对这个
Jake: Yes, this one
Shure:  这
Shure: This
Jake: 对啊得有一个包嘛
Jake: Yeah, it needs a bag
Shure:  包好沉啊
Shure: The bag is so heavy
Lucia: 哈哈哈我不会说出去的
Lucia: Hahaha, I won't tell anyone
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Lucia: 快乐吃瓜哈哈
Lucia: Happily eating melons, haha
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Alice:什么鬼
Alice: What the heck
Alice:魔鬼我错过了什么
Alice: What the heck did I miss
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahaha
Lucia: 没错过是吧
Lucia: You didn't miss anything, right?
Lucia: 你问微微哈哈
Lucia: You can ask Tasha, haha
Tasha: 什么都没有
Tasha: Nothing at all
Tasha: 啦啦啦
Tasha: La la la
Katrina:  我还带了加绒卫衣呢
Katrina: I even brought a fleece sweatshirt
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh
Jake: 这确实出不去对吧
Jake: You really can't get out, right?
Tasha: 便民空间
Tasha: Convenient space
Tasha: 里面没有便民超市
Tasha: There's no convenience store inside
Jake: 那这个空间是干嘛的呢
Jake: So what's this space for?
Tasha: 类似于那种社区空间
Tasha: It's kind of like a community space
Jake: 打麻将用的
Jake: For playing mahjong
Tasha: 呃也许吧
Tasha: Uh, maybe
Lucia: 还有乒乓球估计
Lucia: Probably has ping pong too
Tasha: 读书
Tasha: Reading
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh
Tasha: 乒乓球
Tasha: Ping pong
Jake: 那这也
Jake: Well, this also...
Tasha: 哎但这有卖水的门口
Tasha: But there's a water seller at the entrance
Katrina:  那好像能出去
Katrina: Then it looks like you can get out
Katrina:  出去就过来
Katrina: Just come over after going out.
Katrina:  应该这种修的这种道都会用
Katrina: This kind of path will probably use it.
Lucia: 有被晒到
Lucia: Got some sun.
Shure:  我们的野餐
Shure: Our picnic.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Shure:  我们的野餐就是刚刚在在那个栏杆上
Shure: Our picnic was just over there by the railing.
Lucia: 其实已经吃掉一盒了
Lucia: We already finished one box, actually.
Shure:  然后吃披萨
Shure: Then we ate pizza.
Jake: 跟鱼一起吃披萨对
Jake: Eating pizza with fish, right.
Shure:  然后爆掉一个手串
Shure: And then a bracelet broke.
Tasha: 什么生态共享
Tasha: What kind of ecological sharing?
Lucia: 啊他说他在说我们的野餐计划
Lucia: Ah, he's talking about our picnic plan.
Lucia: 就是刚才和鱼一起
Lucia: Just now, with the fish.
Tasha: 生态共享
Tasha: Ecological sharing.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Right.
Jake: 还有第二餐
Jake: There's a second meal too.
Jake: 其实我们还有几个披萨
Jake: Actually, we still have a few pizzas.
Lucia: 这次喂谁呢哈哈哈
Lucia: Who are we feeding this time? Hahaha.
Tasha: 还有一盒
Tasha: There's still one box left.
Jake: 哈哈哈我们还有一盒披萨
Jake: Hahaha, we still have one box of pizza.
Katrina:  被留当晚饭了
Katrina: Saved for dinner.
Lucia: 可是这里没有那个
Lucia: But there's no...
Tasha: 好像是羊肉披萨
Tasha: Seems like it's lamb pizza.
Tasha: 新
Tasha: New.
Lucia: 没有那个海鸥耶
Lucia: There's no seagulls here.
Jake: 北京竟然没有海鸥
Jake: No seagulls in Beijing?
Tasha: 北京为什么会有海鸥
Tasha: Why would there be seagulls in Beijing?
Lucia: 北京也不靠海吧好像
Lucia: Beijing isn't by the sea, right?
Katrina:  我身上穿的就是海鸥
Katrina: I'm wearing seagulls.
Tasha: 噔噔噔噔
Tasha: Dun dun dun dun.
Tasha: 不行了
Tasha: I can't anymore.
Tasha: 又晒又热
Tasha: It's too sunny and hot.
Lucia: 行我要两个都摘掉我就给他拿下来
Lucia: Okay, I'll take off both, I'll just take it off for him.
Lucia: 别掉了
Lucia: Don't drop it.
Jake: 你这身上设备挺多
Jake: You've got a lot of equipment on you.
Jake: 哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Lucia: 对我带了个耳机
Lucia: Yeah, I'm wearing headphones.
Jake: 对很赛博
Jake: Looks very cyber.
Lucia: 我已经为了照顾这个眼镜没有戴大
Lucia: I didn't wear the big ones to take care of these glasses.
Tasha: 这是要出去了吗
Tasha: Are we going out now?
Lucia: 戴了头戴耳机了哈哈
Lucia: Wearing the headset now, haha.
Alice:可以出去
Alice: We can go out now.
Tasha: 已经出去了
Tasha: Already went out.
Tasha: 都没有遇到水
Tasha: Didn't encounter any water.
Jake: 没有水
Jake: No water?
Tasha: 走错路了
Tasha: Took a wrong turn.
Jake: 问问看吧是出哪去了
Jake: Let's ask where we ended up.
Jake: 看看地图吧要不
Jake: Or maybe check the map?
Tasha: 公园就采集完毕了吗
Tasha: Are we done collecting in the park?
Jake: 诶诶诶
Jake: Eh eh eh.
Lucia: 我们走到那个塔那个那里面了吗
Lucia: Did we go inside that tower?
Jake: 最好对
Jake: Best to do that, yeah.
Lucia: 是不是没有呀
Lucia: Did we not?
Lucia: 我我没记得
Lucia: I don’t remember.
Lucia: 我有见到那个塔
Lucia: I saw the tower.
Jake: 我其实是在找水但是没找着
Jake: I was actually looking for water but couldn’t find any.
Lucia: 保利发展控股竟然在这里
Lucia: Can’t believe Poly Real Estate is here.
Alice:蜻蜓跌水
Alice: The dragonfly fell into the water.
Alice:真的吗
Alice: Really?
Lucia: 这片不会都是保利的吧
Lucia: Is this whole area owned by Poly?
Jake: 我们这个路走的确实抽象了一点
Jake: We definitely took a rather abstract route.
Jake: 我们在沿河走离这个公园越来越远
Jake: We are walking along the river, getting further from the park.
Lucia: 啊哈嗯
Lucia: Ah ha, hmm.
Jake: 哈哈哈可以这就是
Jake: Hahaha, well, this is...
Lucia: 这个是符合符合计划的吗嗯
Lucia: Is this part of the plan?
Jake: 可能没有特别符合
Jake: Probably not exactly.
Lucia: 那我们怎么办
Lucia: So what do we do?
Jake: 那我们在可能绕回去吧
Jake: Maybe we should turn back.
Lucia: 要绕回去呢
Lucia: We need to turn back?
Lucia: 我们修正一下路线
Lucia: Let’s adjust our route.
Jake: 好的
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 可恶路线选错了
Tasha: Darn, we picked the wrong route.
Shure:  像我们去超市的时候再买水
Shure: Let's buy water when we go to the supermarket.
Jake: 那可能有点这边真的没有水哈
Jake: That might be better, there's really no water here.
Jake: 这可是居民区的呀
Jake: This is a residential area.
Jake: 我们已经
Jake: We already...
Shure:  要走到小区里
Shure: Have to go into the neighborhood.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Katrina:  刚那便利店
Katrina: That convenience store we passed...
Katrina:  只能从这出去再绕回去
Katrina: We have to go out and loop back.
Jake: 对我们偏离路线偏离了一公里
Jake: Yeah, we deviated from the route by one kilometer.
Jake: 哈哈哈没有关系没有关系
Jake: Hahaha, it's okay, it's okay.
Shure: 没有关系
Shure: It's okay.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure:  一定是在J人的计划中吧
Shure: It must be part of J's plan.
Katrina:  yeah
Katrina: Yeah.
Lucia: 一定有他的道理
Lucia: There's gotta be a reason for it.
Alice:那我们走水路吧
Alice: Then let's take the water route.
Alice:感觉那里面凉快
Alice: It feels cooler there.
Lucia: 我们可以沿着它走
Lucia: We can walk along it.
Jake: 我们可以过个马路得了来都来了
Jake: We can cross the road since we're already here.
Alice:来都来了
Alice: Since we're already here.
Lucia: 那就我走到保利的那块地坪上去
Lucia: Then I'll walk over to that area by Poly.
Jake: 对面是不是也没有什么
Jake: There's nothing on the other side, right?
Jake: 还是那就走水路回
Jake: Or we can take the water route back.
Jake: 还是这边阴凉一点
Jake: It's cooler over here.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake: 好吧
Jake: Alright.
Alice:我们不能游过去吗
Alice: Can't we swim across?
Jake: 可以
Jake: We can.
Shure:  但眼镜不防水
Shure: But my glasses aren't waterproof.
Jake: 我们
Jake: We...
Alice:谁会游泳呢
Alice: Who can swim?
Lucia: 其实我会哈哈
Lucia: Actually, I can. Haha.
Jake: 走吧
Jake: Let's go.
其他人：原路返回吗
Others: Are we going back the same way?
Jake: 回头
Jake: Turn back.
Jake: 回到起点
Jake: Back to the start.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Tasha: 啊什么
Tasha: What?
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 我们可以不回从这再去下一个地点
Shure: We can not go back and head to the next place from here.
Katrina:  要不要先买水再回到起点
Katrina: Should we get water before heading back to the start?
Jake: 也可以水在这附近还是
Jake: We can do that. Is the water around here or...
Katrina:  水就刚刚那个便利店
Katrina: Water's at that convenience store we passed.
Katrina:  只是从这绕绕出去一下
Katrina: Just a little detour from here.
Jake: 好那绕一圈
Jake: Alright, let's take a detour.
Jake: 再绕一圈
Jake: One more round.
Jake: 把小区给建了
Jake: Let's build the neighborhood.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 脸不可以吗哈哈哈
Lucia: Can't use my face? Hahaha
Jake: 咱就说要买水
Jake: We just said we wanted to buy water
Jake: 光天化日之下我们能干什么
Jake: What can we do in broad daylight
Katrina:  应该能进去吧这边
Katrina: We should be able to get in from here
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes
Lucia: 拍VLOG吧哈哈哈
Lucia: Let's shoot a vlog, haha
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 对不起
Lucia: Sorry
Alice:没有没有没有
Alice: No, no, it's fine
Alice:我在想事情
Alice: I was just thinking
Alice:我在想我五一怎么回家
Alice: I was thinking about how to go home during May Day
Alice:要不要回家
Alice: Should I go home?
Alice:你的五一安排是什么
Alice: What are your plans for May Day?
Lucia: 我五一安排在家躺着
Lucia: My plan is to stay at home and relax
Lucia: 因为五一放假出去玩的人太多了
Lucia: Because there are too many people traveling during the holiday
Alice:对我也是
Alice: Yeah, same here
Alice:我就在想
Alice: I was just thinking
Alice:回家躺跟在寝室躺
Alice: Is there any difference between lying at home and lying in the dorm?
Alice:有什么本质上特别的区别吗
Alice: Is there any substantial difference?
Tasha: 我觉得这就会有便利店
Tasha: I think there will be a convenience store
Jake: 对这边一条街的超市前面
Jake: Yes, in front of the supermarket on this street
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah
Jake: 我看到了两个字
Jake: I saw two words
Jake: 超市对
Jake: Supermarket, right
Tasha: 超市好
Tasha: Supermarket, great
Tasha: 你眼睛睁好我看不见
Tasha: Open your eyes wide, I can't see
Jake: 是吧
Jake: Right
Tasha: 你不是近视吗
Tasha: Aren't you nearsighted?
Jake: 带隐形眼镜的呀
Jake: I'm wearing contacts
Jake: 有超市好强啊
Jake: It's great to have a supermarket
Tasha: 看见
Tasha: I see it
Tasha: 你骂我了
Tasha: Did you just scold me?
Jake: 为什么是我
Jake: Why would it be me?
Tasha: 你跟我说过话
Tasha: You talked to me
Jake: 啊哈哈
Jake: Ahaha
Jake: 羽毛球
Jake: Badminton
Lucia: 这是哪天啊
Lucia: What day is it?
Lucia: 清明节吗
Lucia: Is it Qingming Festival?
Alice:对
Alice: Yes
Alice:野营的人比树还多
Alice: There are more campers than trees
Alice:我那天快被吓死了
Alice: I was so scared that day.
Alice:但那天天还蛮好的
Alice: But the weather was pretty good that day.
Alice:我们去逛了
Alice: We went for a walk.
Alice:不对我们去放风筝了
Alice: No, we went to fly kites.
Alice:你最近会在北京待吗
Alice: Are you staying in Beijing recently?
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Yeah.
Lucia: 我要是在北京待我还得专门租个房子
Lucia: If I stay in Beijing, I would have to rent a place.
Katrina:  喵喵喵喵
Katrina: Meow meow meow meow.
Alice:那你是这个结束之后先回家还是
Alice: So, after this, are you going home first or...?
Lucia: 我现在是这样想的
Lucia: That's what I'm thinking now.
Lucia: 不过我也有可能需要在北京办点事情
Lucia: But I might need to take care of some things in Beijing.
Lucia: 所以不是很确定
Lucia: So, not really sure.
Alice:有无怡宝有看到了
Alice: Have you seen any Yibao water?
Jake: 呃可以报吧
Jake: Uh, you can report it.
Jake: 你们扫吧
Jake: You guys scan it.
Alice:有人喝矿泉水吗
Alice: Anyone wants mineral water?
其他人：我们一起付还是单付
Others: Are we paying together or separately?
Jake: 一起付
Jake: Together.
Lucia: 你要哪个
Lucia: Which one do you want?
Jake: 我不知道
Jake: I don't know.
Jake: 帮我选一个吧
Jake: Help me choose one.
Lucia: 你有选择恐惧症吗
Lucia: Do you have decision anxiety?
Jake: 谢谢你
Jake: Thank you.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahaha.
Jake: 我知道我可以say no
Jake: I know I can say no.
Jake: 我不能我不知道这个吧
Jake: I can't, I don't know this one.
Alice:这个吧
Alice: How about this one?
Jake: 这个也可以
Jake: This one works too.
Lucia: 困了累了喝东鹏特饮
Lucia: Tired and sleepy? Drink Dongpeng Special Drink.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 啊哎
Lucia: Ah, hey.
Lucia: 怎么能一样啊
Lucia: How can it be the same?
其他人：123456
Others: 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
其他人：32一共
Others: 32 in total.
Jake: 啊扫的这么快
Jake: Wow, you scanned so fast.
其他人：32  35
Others: 32, 35.
Jake:  OK行
Jake: OK, fine.
Jake: 我怎么付你
Jake: How do I pay you?
Jake: 我扫这个行
Jake: Can I scan this?
其他人：行
Others: Alright.
Jake: 35
Jake: 好嘞
Jake: Got it.
Jake: 呃走
Jake: Uh, let's go.
其他人：微信收款35元
Others: Received 35 yuan on WeChat.
Jake: 走
Jake: Let's go.
Katrina:  你拿我营养快线干啥
Katrina: Why did you take my nutrition drink?
Shure:  拿我脉动干什么
Shure: Why did you take my drink?
Shure:  我说你怼我干什么
Shure: Why are you picking on me?
Katrina:  我以为我记记记错了
Katrina: I thought I remembered wrong.
Shure:  而且我还没没什么反应
Shure: And I didn't even react.
Jake: 一个7新币的水
Jake: A 7 SGD water.
Jake: 哈哈哈也可以
Jake: Hahaha, that's fine too.
Lucia: 这个7新币吗
Lucia: This is 7 SGD?
Jake: 没有就是花了35嘛
Jake: No, just spent 35 yuan.
Jake: 相当于我买了一个七新币的水
Jake: It's like I bought a 7 SGD water.
Tasha: 没事
Tasha: It's okay.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
其他人：真诡异
Others: So weird.
Shure:  怎么说下一站吗
Shure: Are we talking about the next stop?
其他人：去哪
Others: Where to?
Katrina:  下一站去哪
Katrina: Where's the next stop?
Tasha: 你们前两天有这种在外面徒步的活动吗
Tasha: Did you have any outdoor hiking activities a few days ago?
Tasha: 没有哦你
Tasha: No, you?
其他人：我今天一来就遇到这种
Others: I encountered this as soon as I came today.
Tasha: 你不想走是吗
Tasha: You don't want to go, right?
Shure:  找一个大一点的
Shure: Find a bigger one.
其他人：没事还好还好
Others: It's okay, it's fine.
Lucia: 大一点
Lucia: Bigger.
Shure:  上张超吧还是
Shure: Let's go to Changchao.
Tasha: 啊我不想走
Tasha: Ah, I don't want to go.
其他人：我也不想走
Others: I don't want to go either.
Tasha: 哈哈哈我
Tasha: Hahaha, I...
Tasha: 你只是一开始想说但是又不好意思说
Tasha: You just wanted to say it from the start but were too shy to say it.
Tasha: 一旦我发起这个话题你就会很认同
Tasha: Once I brought it up, you totally agreed.
Tasha: 小蝴蝶是这样的
Tasha: Little Butterfly is like that.
Katrina:  大超市
Katrina: Big supermarket.
Shure:  搜一搜勾人
Shure: Search for it.
其他人：在大超市里走还好一点
Others: Walking in a big supermarket is better.
Tasha: 嗯很凉快
Tasha: Yeah, it's cooler.
Katrina:  这200米居然有个盒马先生
Katrina: There's a Hema store just 200 meters away.
Katrina:  200米居然只有
Katrina: Only 200 meters away.
Jake: 一定有点
Jake: There must be something.
Shure:  四四四百米
Shure: Four hundred meters.
Katrina:  400米有个盒马先生
Katrina: A Hema store 400 meters away.
Jake: 走吧走
Jake: Let's go, let's go.
Shure:  走吧
Shure: Let's go.
Katrina:  是盒马是吗
Katrina: Is it a Hema store?
Shure:  走带路
Shure: Lead the way.
其他人：盒马可以把晚饭解决了吧
Others: Hema can take care of dinner, right?
Katrina:  那就盒马
Katrina: Then Hema it is.
Katrina:  直接买那个肉
Katrina: Let's just buy the meat.
Katrina:  然后烤肉
Katrina: And then barbecue it.
Jake: 还有对
Jake: Yeah, right.
Tasha: 那还回公园吗
Tasha: Are we going back to the park?
Jake: 不回了不回了吧
Jake: No, let's not go back.
Lucia: 会不会有点晒啊
Lucia: Will it be too sunny?
Lucia: 还好谢谢
Lucia: It's okay, thanks.
Jake: 好绿啊
Jake: So green.
Jake: 哼哼
Jake: Hmm.
Jake: 不能更绿了
Jake: Couldn't be greener.
Jake: 好吧啊
Jake: Alright.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Jake: 不能更绿了
Jake: Couldn't be greener.
Tasha: 不能更绿了好
Tasha: Couldn't be greener, right.
Jake: 和小绿人合个影
Jake: Let's take a photo with the little green man.
Tasha: 不行眼镜
Tasha: No, my glasses.
Tasha: 不行怎么这么帅
Tasha: No, how is he so handsome?
Jake: 好好太绿了
Jake: Alright, it's too green.
Tasha: 好哈哈哈
Tasha: Okay, haha.
Tasha: 我要不要帮你把水放到书包里
Tasha: Should I help you put the water in the backpack?
Jake: 不要我还要喝
Jake: No, I still need to drink it.
Tasha: 这样就可以解放你的双手了
Tasha: This way your hands will be free.
Jake: 啊我为什么要解放双手
Jake: Why do I need free hands?
Tasha: 好你想要手上拿的东西是吗
Tasha: Do you want to carry something in your hands?
Jake: 因为我可以
Jake: Because I can.
Jake: 没有我还一会还要喝呢
Jake: No, I need to drink it later.
Tasha: 哦我还以为你是喜欢手上拿东西
Tasha: Oh, I thought you liked carrying stuff.
Jake: 哦没有没有
Jake: Oh, no, no.
Tasha: 可恶
Tasha: Darn.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Jake: 哈哈哈哈怎么了
Jake: Hahaha, what's up?
Tasha: 因为要是帮你把水放到你的书包里
Tasha: Because if I help you put the water in your backpack
Tasha: 我就可以把我这也偷偷塞进去
Tasha: I can secretly put mine in there too
Tasha: 如果你喜欢手上拿东西
Tasha: If you like holding things in your hand
Jake: 哦哦哦那你不喝
Jake: Oh oh oh, then you won't drink it?
Tasha: 就可以手上再多拿一瓶
Tasha: Then you can hold another bottle in your hand
Jake: 你不喝了是吧
Jake: So you won't drink it, right?
Tasha: 嗯没有没有
Tasha: No, no
Tasha: 是的是的
Tasha: Yes, yes
Tasha: 呵呵没关系
Tasha: Haha, it's okay
Jake: 哎呀通州公安局
Jake: Oh, Tongzhou Police Station
Jake: 大家想想大家想想有没有要要报案的
Jake: Everyone think, think, does anyone need to report something?
Tasha: 该进去了
Tasha: Time to go in
Jake: 顺便就哈哈哈哈
Jake: While we're at it, hahaha
Tasha: 我迟到了
Tasha: I'm late
Tasha: i'm late
Jake: late what
Jake: Late for what?
Jake: 哇好快好牛啊
Jake: Wow, that was fast and awesome
Jake: 一切都在掌握之中
Jake: Everything is under control
Jake: 啊不用不用
Jake: Ah, no need, no need
Jake: 逛逛商场
Jake: Let's browse the mall
Alice:风云再起
Alice: Storm's brewing again
Jake: 这个商场档次如何
Jake: How's the quality of this mall?
Tasha: 那我们要不要去看一下风云再起
Tasha: Should we go check out the storm brewing again?
Alice:你要抓娃娃
Alice: Do you want to catch dolls?
Jake: 风云再起是什么
Jake: What's "storm brewing again"?
Lucia: 呃呃看起来像健身俱乐部
Lucia: Uh, looks like a fitness club
Alice:呃电
Alice: Uh, it's a
Jake: 抓娃娃的
Jake: A claw machine
Tasha: 抓娃娃了嗯
Tasha: Let's catch some dolls, yeah
Jake: 行啊那抓会啊
Jake: Sure, let's catch some
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Lucia: 可以抓吗
Lucia: Can we catch them?
Jake: 抓走
Jake: Let's catch them
Tasha: 走
Tasha: Let's go
Shure:    不行
Shure: No
Tasha: 什么不行
Tasha: What do you mean no?
Jake: 什么不行
Jake: What do you mean no?
Lucia: 哈什么不行
Lucia: Huh, what do you mean no?
Jake: 都行都行
Jake: Whatever, whatever.
Alice:他们在另一个话题
Alice: They're on another topic.
Jake: 哦什么不行啊
Jake: Oh, what's not okay?
Tasha: 哦哈
Tasha: Oh, ha.
Jake: 什么不行
Jake: What's not okay?
Tasha: 不知道我以为风云再起不行
Tasha: I don't know, I thought "Wind and Cloud Reborn" wasn't okay.
Tasha: 那他就别玩哈哈
Tasha: Then he shouldn't play it, haha.
Jake: 风云再起为啥不行
Jake: Why is "Wind and Cloud Reborn" not okay?
Lucia: 我觉得看起来像啊
Lucia: I think it looks like it.
Lucia: 那有可能是游戏厅旁边写了一个游戏
Lucia: Maybe there's a game written next to the arcade.
Tasha: 肯定是游戏厅都已经
Tasha: It's definitely the arcade already.
Alice:我的儿子怎么在这
Alice: Why is my son here?
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Jake: 哦你的儿子哦
Jake: Oh, your son, oh.
Alice:旅行青蛙
Alice: Traveling Frog.
Lucia: 哦蛙儿子
Lucia: Oh, Frog son.
Alice:我的儿子怎么在这
Alice: Why is my son here?
Jake: 哎你
Jake: Hey, you.
Jake: 你和他
Jake: You and he.
Lucia: 他旅行到这里了
Lucia: He traveled here.
Tasha: 适配是吗
Tasha: Is it compatible?
Jake: 哈哈颜色挺到位是吧
Jake: Haha, the color is quite on point, right?
Tasha: 嗯嗯火锅
Tasha: Yeah, yeah, hotpot.
Tasha: 呃不是烧烤
Tasha: Uh, no, barbecue.
Tasha: 让AI采集一下
Tasha: Let AI collect some data.
Tasha: 破解一下娃娃机的秘密
Tasha: Crack the secret of the claw machine.
Lucia: 那个好像是编好程的
Lucia: That seems to be programmed.
Lucia: 就是他
Lucia: Like it.
Lucia: 隔几次就会有一次抓得比较紧的时候
Lucia: It grabs tighter every few times.
Jake: 哎我们先
Jake: Hey, let's.
Jake: 我我们我们先在商场里边整点活吧
Jake: Let's, let's do something in the mall first.
Jake: 先晃悠晃悠
Jake: Just wander around.
Jake: 然后再买东西再提走对
Jake: Then buy stuff and carry it out, right?
Lucia: 可以
Lucia: Sure.
Katrina:  可以可以
Katrina: Sure, sure.
Shure:  我们去小米买点电电池哈哈哈
Shure: Let's go to Xiaomi and buy some batteries, hahaha.
Lucia: 好特卖哦
Lucia: Such a sale.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Katrina:  对啊好特卖
Katrina: Yeah, such a sale.
Lucia: 好特卖
Lucia: Such a sale.
Katrina:  我最喜欢买
Katrina: I love buying
Katrina:  好特卖好特卖好特卖好特卖
Katrina: Great sales, great sales, great sales, great sales
Lucia: 对对对因为比较便宜
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, yeah, because it's cheaper
Jake: 好好特卖是什么
Jake: What do you mean by "great sales"?
Katrina:  便宜货呵呵呵
Katrina: Cheap stuff, hehe
Lucia: 那个特价店对对对
Lucia: That discount store, yeah, yeah
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Jake: 哦哦好
Jake: Oh, okay
Katrina:  就是他都是那种临期的
Katrina: It's all about near-expiry stuff
Jake: 等等会等会
Jake: Wait, wait a second
Jake: 我我们好像还没对齐
Jake: I think we're not aligned yet
Jake: 现在甚至现在
Jake: Even now, even now
Jake: 对一下把把把他叫过来来来来
Jake: Let's get it aligned, call him over here, come on
Shure:  哦我们出发的时候忘看这个
Shure: Oh, we forgot to check this when we left
Jake: 对没看这个东西对好
Jake: Yeah, we didn't check this thing, right
Jake: 3:47 行
Jake: 3:47, okay
Alice:你抓娃娃厉害吗
Alice: Are you good at claw machines?
Tasha: 呃没关系
Tasha: Uh, it's okay
Tasha: 杨老板付钱
Tasha: Jake will pay
Tasha: 觉得在团购上买会不会便宜
Tasha: Do you think buying on group deals will be cheaper?
Jake: 100个币是什么意思
Jake: What does 100 tokens mean?
Jake: 100个币抓几次
Jake: How many times can you play with 100 tokens?
Tasha: 可能抓30次吧
Tasha: Maybe 30 times
Lucia: 有的5个币只能抓一次
Lucia: Some machines cost 5 tokens per play
Tasha: 30次吧
Tasha: 30 times, I guess
Lucia: 30次大概
Lucia: About 30 times
Jake: 那我100个币你们你们自由分配
Jake: Then I'll give you all 100 tokens, you guys can distribute them
Shure:  就位好
Shure: All set
Katrina:  好吧那就微信购
Katrina: Okay, then we can buy on WeChat
Jake: 好吧好行
Jake: Alright, okay
Katrina:  是不是便宜点
Katrina: Isn't it cheaper?
Shure:  呼呼
Shure: Hoo hoo
Lucia: 看一下美团有吗
Lucia: Check if Meituan has it
Katrina:  就扫这个嘛那89
Katrina: Just scan this, it's 89
Tasha: 我也这么觉得的
Tasha: I think so too
Lucia: 那个微信购币好像89100币
Lucia: The WeChat token purchase is like 89 for 100 tokens
Shure:  扫
Shure: Scan it
Katrina:  耶老板万岁哈哈
Katrina: Yay, long live the boss, haha
Shure:  若每人夸一句杨哥好帅
Shure: Everyone should praise Jake for being so handsome
Jake: 呵呵呵
Jake: Hehe
Alice:有那个大众点评哎
Alice: Oh, there's Dazhong Dianping.
Alice:不对那叫啥来着团购
Alice: No, wait, what's it called... group buying.
Jake: 100个币89是吧
Jake: 100 coins for 89, right?
Tasha: 这个会不会便宜一些
Tasha: Would this be cheaper?
Shure:  应该差不多耶
Shure: Should be about the same.
Jake: 就这样吧go
Jake: Let's go with this. Go.
Jake: 还行
Jake: It's okay.
Jake: 哦不然还得剪是吧
Jake: Oh, otherwise we have to cut it, right?
Jake: 又是一个离谱的数据
Jake: Another ridiculous number.
Katrina:  这多少
Katrina: What's the number?
Jake: 对吧
Jake: Right?
Katrina:  84 他这89
Katrina: 84, he has 89.
Katrina:  应该差不多吧
Katrina: Should be about the same.
Katrina:  老板觉得5块钱不是钱
Katrina: The boss thinks 5 bucks is nothing.
Jake: 他动了
Jake: He moved.
Shure:  啊你需要点一下对哦对
Shure: Oh, you need to click it. Right, right.
Lucia: 好神奇
Lucia: So amazing.
Katrina:  来吧
Katrina: Come on.
Shure:  来吧来吧
Shure: Come on, come on.
Jake: 来吧
Jake: Come on.
Lucia: 来吧
Lucia: Come on.
其他人： 我们分一下
Others: Let's divide it up.
Alice:一人抓两把得了
Alice: Everyone grab two handfuls.
Katrina:  抓娃娃去
Katrina: Let's go grab some toys.
Lucia: 是多少个啊
Lucia: How many are there?
Katrina:  你会抓娃娃吗
Katrina: Do you know how to grab toys?
Katrina:  开玩笑这我没抓到过
Katrina: Just kidding, I've never caught one.
Shure:  开玩笑高玩好吗
Shure: Kidding, I'm a pro at this.
Lucia: 123456789
Jake: 我我们我们也抓去
Jake: We... we should go grab some too.
Alice:来两个吧
Alice: Let's get two.
Jake: 哈哈哈我们也抓吧
Jake: Hahaha, let's go grab some too.
Jake: 你你我看你我我拿拿俩吧
Jake: You, you... I'll take two.
Alice:我们一起抓吧
Alice: Let's grab together.
Alice:啊我不怎么玩
Alice: Ah, I don't play much.
Jake: 哎对可以啊可以啊你可以
Jake: Yeah, sure, you can do it.
Lucia: 我再拿一个吧
Lucia: I'll take another one.
Jake: 没事没事没事没事找我领就好
Jake: It's okay, it's okay, just come to me for it.
Alice:你想抓什么
Alice: What do you want to grab?
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Huh?
Lucia: 很出师不利的
Lucia: This is not a good start.
Tasha: 我带你去玩一个
Tasha: I'll take you to play something.
Jake: 走
Jake: Let's go.
Jake: 抓什么呀
Jake: What are we catching?
Tasha: 我其实想玩那个
Tasha: Actually, I wanted to play that one.
Tasha: 但好多人呀
Tasha: But there are too many people.
Jake: 这是浪费了我一个币子是吧
Jake: Did I just waste a coin?
Jake: 哈哈哈那那边有那个架子鼓
Jake: Haha, look, there's a drum set over there.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
其他人：在找我们吗
Others: Are they looking for us?
其他人：还是嗯
Others: Or, hmm?
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
其他人：我在找你
Others: I'm looking for you.
Tasha:  哦好的
Tasha: Oh, okay.
其他人：他们在看修硕打架子鼓
Others: They're watching Shure play the drums.
Tasha: 哦哦啊哈
Tasha: Oh, oh, haha.
Tasha: 但是我们手上一个币都没有
Tasha: But we don't have any coins.
其他人：啊你一个币都没有
Others: Ah, you don't have any coins?
Tasha: 哈哈哈没关系
Tasha: Hahaha, it's okay.
Jake: 雨轩呢
Jake: Where's Yuxuan?
Jake: 哎雨轩呢
Jake: Hey, where's Yuxuan?
Jake: 不知道去好好找他一下
Jake: I don't know, go look for him properly.
Jake: 我我去围观
Jake: I'll go watch.
Jake: 围围观那谁
Jake: Go watch who?
Jake: 打架子鼓
Jake: Playing the drums.
Lucia: 没事又绕过来了我说
Lucia: It's okay, we came around again, I said.
Jake: 四四个币子
Jake: Four coins.
Jake: 你要水平高是不是可以连打
Jake: If you're good, can you keep playing?
Katrina:  哎呦表演才艺了
Katrina: Oh wow, showing off some talent.
Tasha: 只差那么一点
Tasha: Just missed it by a bit.
Jake: 挺好挺好挺好
Jake: Pretty good, pretty good.
Jake: 你抓了吗
Jake: Did you catch it?
Tasha: 没有币哈哈
Tasha: No coins, haha.
Jake: 啊在哪啊
Jake: Ah, where is it?
Tasha: 在在这里
Tasha: It's here.
Jake: 你要抓谁
Jake: Who are you trying to catch?
Jake: 这什么呀
Jake: What's this?
Tasha: 就是你看下上面的乌龟要比下面的小
Tasha: See, the turtle on the top is smaller than the one on the bottom.
Tasha: 只要叠到叠5个
Tasha: We just need to stack five.
Jake: OK
Jake: OK.
Tasha: 就可以拿到任意一个奖品
Tasha: Then we can get any prize we want.
Jake: 这么牛逼
Jake: That's awesome.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Jake: 看你表演
Jake: Show me how it's done.
Tasha: 你帮我投吧
Tasha: You help me throw.
Tasha: 你想要哪个
Tasha: Which one do you want?
Tasha: 我帮你抓
Tasha: I'll grab it for you.
Jake: 哈哈真的呀
Jake: Haha, really?
Tasha: 真的真的假的
Tasha: Really, seriously.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Tasha: 啊哦
Tasha: Oh no.
Tasha: 啊哦你看
Tasha: Oh no, look.
Tasha: 这样子就不太好叠了
Tasha: It's hard to stack like this.
Jake: 哦哦我明白了啊
Jake: Oh, I see now.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Yeah.
Jake: 这就挂了是吧
Jake: So it's game over, right?
Tasha: 你来
Tasha: Your turn.
Tasha: 我其实想要这个
Tasha: Actually, I want this one.
Jake: 哦好
Jake: Oh, okay.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Jake: 要叠5个是吗
Jake: We need to stack five, right?
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yes.
Tasha: 他会变大变小开始
Tasha: It'll change sizes, start now.
Tasha: OK你叠好了
Tasha: OK, you stacked it.
Tasha: 第一个
Tasha: The first one.
Tasha: 哎
Tasha: Oops.
Jake: 这么快
Jake: That was fast.
Tasha: 这难度本来就是二哈哈
Tasha: The difficulty is just level two, haha.
Jake: 这就挂了
Jake: It's game over already.
Tasha: 你这样不行
Tasha: You can't do it like this.
Tasha: 我们再玩最后一次吧
Tasha: Let's play one last time.
Jake: 没关系
Jake: No problem.
Tasha: 嗷
Tasha: Oh no.
Jake:啊这都不行啊再来一次
Jake: Ah, this still doesn't work, let's try again.
Tasha: 啊哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Ah hahaha.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake: 哦我去
Jake: Oh my gosh.
Tasha: 啊哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Ahahahahahahahaha
Jake: 啊啊
Jake: Ahhh
Jake: 啊哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha
Jake: 转悠转悠去
Jake: Let's go for a walk